at Dr Tim
cooksly speaking on Sky News talk to
he's the president of the society for
acute medicine he was the senior medic
who called for a major incidence in the
NHS a four Nation emergency strategy
um and so the lib Dems responding to
that Daisy Cooper said this this is a
life or death situation for huge numbers
of patients the NHS forgive me we're
just going to interrupt you there we'll
come back to you a little later we're
just going to cross live to Perth in
Scotland where there's a press
conference taking place following the
deaths of those people in the early
hours of this morning circumstances of
what's happened this morning and our
officers are working closely in joint
investigation with the Scottish fire and
rescue service
I would like to thank the police
officers fire officers and ambulance
Personnel that responded to this
incident this morning
for their professionalism in response
and to our partner agencies for the
support that is being provided
I would ask for patience from the local
community as local roads may remain
closed for some time
and as I'm sure you will appreciate
inquiries are at an early stage and
therefore no further details of those
involved will be released at this time
and we will clearly provide more
information to the media as it becomes
appropriate and right to do so thank you
so no further questions at this stage so
no sorry 11 people had treatment here uh
but didn't require any hospitalization
nobody else has gone to hospital that's
it thank you very much
afternoon folks my name is Jason Sharp
I'm a commander and local senior officer
for Perth I guess 20.
can I start again
good afternoon everyone my name is Jason
Sharp area commander for perfect and
Ross Angus and Dundee
this was a very complex instant
we are tragically three people who were
pronounced dead at the scene
our thoughts are very much with the
media family
and friends at this difficult time
our firefighters work extremely hard in
a very complex and challenging
environment
to prevent the further spread of fire
and damage where possible
at its height with nine fire appliances
in attendance with over 60 firefighters
we're currently still in attendance to
make sure the scene is safe
I'd like to thank our crews and our
other emergency partners and local
Authority for their support
our firefighters and Community Action
teams have have and will continue to
engage in ensure safety in this area and
we will continue to work closely closely
with stakeholders and police Scotland in
any subsequent investigation
thank you
thanks ever so much everyone
um we're not expecting to release any
more information today
and we may have our press conference
tomorrow
well there we have uh the latest here in
uh Perth on this painstaking operation
from both the police and the fire
Services updating us on this uh very
tragic incident that unfolded here in
this hotel the new County Hotel just
after five o'clock this morning the fire
was extinguished around half past six
and uh officers here have been updating
us let me just run you through exactly
what has been said no questions at all
from any of the officers here this
afternoon but uh the fire was
extinguished at 6 30 this morning and at
that stage it became clear that three
people had lost their lives here in
Perth this morning 11 people were
treated with minor injuries no one
additional was taken to hospital
following what occurred in the early
hours now we have seen footage of this
incident unfolded Flames coming out of
the hotel window in the early hours of
this morning clearly a very traumatic
event and Sky News has also spoken to
one guest inside at the property inside
that hotel and she has told us the lady
wants to call herself Barbara she says
she is lucky to be alive she said she
recently returned from abroad and while
she's looking for permanent
accommodation here in Scotland she was
staying inside the new County hotel when
this incident unfolded overnight she
said she and her husband had been
staying in the room directly above where
the fire broke out and they were awoken
by the sound of alarms they recalled
that frantic moment where they were
trying to leave at that building those
painful moments where they were hearing
and seeing exactly what was unfolding
and it's something that they were too
emotional to talk in too much detail
about but certainly it has been a very
traumatic time now the emergency
Services here have not been taking any
questions about exactly what the
situation is we we're wanting to ask a
number of questions about the state of
this hotel at where their previous
concerns in the recent years in the
recent months about the conditions
inside there not drawing any conclusions
of course at this stage but it is
something that has been brought up by
that Resident that I was telling you
about apparently at that Resident
suggests that concerns were raised
um at a point when she was staying in
this hotel again Emergency Services not
giving us any information at this stage
at parathink and Ross Council I've also
issued a statement sending their
heartfelt condolences to the three
people who have lost their lives here on
the very early stages of this new year
and also we have also been hearing that
neighboring properties were evacuated as
well and that a dog has died but just to
recap what Emergency Services have been
telling us here that 21 ambulance Crews
60 firefighters were battling Through
the flames in the early hours of this
morning but tragically three people have
died
okay Connor Gillis live for us there in
Perth for now thank you
to our other top story this hour the
government insists it's working
tirelessly to ease pressure on the NHS
following a series of dire warnings from
Health bosses and doctors leaders about
the state of the service well joining me
live is Chris Hobson Who's chief
strategy officer at NHS England thank
you very much for joining us now several
trusts have declared a critical incident
and we're hearing this is the worst
winter ever experienced by the NHS from
various medical bosses